معنا الان من مستشفى الشفاء في مدينه غزه
مراسل الجزيره اسماعيل الغول اهلا بك
اسماعيل الوضع في مدينه غزه وربما في
الشمال يعتبر
الاسوا من الاوضاع ربما في وسط وجنوب
القطاع لعدم وصول اي من المساعدات
للنازحين ان كان في شمال القطاع اقصى
شماله او حتى في قلب المدينه قربنا اكثر
من الاوضاع الانسانيه اذا
تكررت
نعم اذا ما تحدثنا عن الاوضاع الانسانيه
نتحدث فيما قبل عن الوضع الميداني قوات
الاحتلال في الساعات الاخيره قصف التجمع
للمواطنين قرب الدوار الكويتي ووصل الى
مستشفى الشفاء ثلاثه شهداء وهذه للمره
الثالثه تقصف تجمعات المواطنين المنتظره
لدخول المساعدات قرب الدوار الكويتي قبل
ايام استهدفت قوات الاحتلال التجمعات وقع
20 شهيدا في تلك المنطقه وما يقارب 150
اصابه لكن لازالت قوات الاحتلال تقصف كل
من يحاول الحصول على لقمه عيش في ظل الوضع
المعيشي الصعب والوضع الكارثي و نحن على
ابان مجاعه حقيقيه في شمال قطاع غزه في ظل
عدم دخول حتى المساعدات لليوم الرابع على
التوالي لم تدخل قوات الاحتلال المساعدات
الى شمال قطاع غزه بذري ان المجموعات
المستوطنه مجموعات المستوطنين وعائلات
الاسرى تمنع دخول المساعدات الى شمال قطاع
غزه لكن يبدو ان اهداف قوات الاحتلال
تنسجم بشكل مباشر مع اهداف عائلات الاسرى
واهداف ايضا المجموعات المتطرفه
الاسرائيليه في داخل الكيان الاسرائيلي
اما اذا ما تحدثنا عن الوضع المعيشي
والوضع الانساني حتى هذه اللحظه الوضع
كارثي ونحن على حافه مجاعه حقيقيه
بالاضافه الى تخوف كبير من فيضان مياه
الامطار على المواطنين في مختلف المناطق
بالتحديد في اماكن وبرك تجمع مياه الامطار
في منطقه حي الشيخ رضوان ومنطقه حي
الزيتون الذي محطه بي سب الذي فاضت بشكل
حقيقي على مناطق ومراكز الايواء في منطقه
حي الزيتون الان المخاوف حقيقيه والمخاوف
كارثيه في ظل عدم تواف وفر مضخات مياه
تعمل بعد تدمير مضخات المياه من قوات
الاحتلال وتدمير حتى مولدات الكهرباء التي
تعمل على تشغيل هذه المحطه في منطقه حي
الشيخ رضوان الان بلديه غزه ومختلف
المنظمات المشرفه على هذا القطاع عاجزه عن
تقديم الخدمه وحتى سحب مياه الامطار
واعاده ضخها الى مياه البحار هذا بخصوص
مياه الامطار ولا يقل
الوضع قسوه في ظل البرد القارص وساعات
الليل التي تشهد بردا قارص جدا على مخ
متلف المواطنين الذين يعيشون داخل مراكز
الاواء او حتى داخل خيام البرد والشديد
جعل يفتك بعظام هؤلاء المواطنين بالاضافه
الى قد يكون هناك وفاه من لمعظم الاطفال
بسبب عدم توفر ملابس وحتى مراكز ايوا وحتى
اغطيه بعد نزوح هذه العائلات من اماكن
نزوحها في المناطق الشماليه الغربيه وحتى
في المناطق الشرقيه هذه على الوضع
الانساني اما اذا ما تحدثنا عن الوضع
الميداني نحن نتحدث عن اشتباكات ضاريه
وعنيفه لليوم الث عشر بعد المئه في منطقه
شمال غرب مدينه غزه هذه المنطقه الان تشهد
اصوات اسلحه رشاشه وتشهد ايضا اطلاق مدفعي
عنيف بالاضافه الى اشتباكات ضاريه في تلك
المنطقه وتحليق مكثف من طائرات الاحتلال
اما على المناطق الجنوبيه الغربيه هذه
ايضا بعد ان تمحورت قوات الاحتلال وانسحبت
الى المناطق الجنوبيه من هذه المنطقه قرب
دوار النابولسي يبدو ان قوات المقاومه
اوقعت فيما يوم امس او ليله امس بكمين في
قوات الاحتلال حيث اعلنت المقاومه انها
اشتبكت مع ثمانيه جنود في تلك المنطقه لكن
دائما ما يكون الدليل القصف المدفعي
المتواصل هو التغطيه لقوات الاحتلال على
وقوعها في كمين او حتى في اشتباكها
تعنيفها مع قوات المقاومه وهذا دليل واضح
على اعاده انتشار وحدات المقاومه وعناصر
المقاومه في مختلف المحاور خاصه بعد
انسحاب قوات الاحتلال شكرا جزيلا لك ا من
مستشفى الشفاء في مدينه غزه مراسل الجزيره
اسماعيل الغول